on la rencontre de demain à genève
dernière chance de sortir de l'impasse
dans la crise ukrainienne pourquoi
washington menace toujours la russie à
la veille de ce face à face quels sont
les enjeux de ces rencontres est peut-on
s'en sortir c'est l'objet de notre
décryptage
est avec nous pour en parler sur ce
plateau nicolas conc'air porte-parole
des républicains envers six france
bonsoir nicolas conc'air merci d'être
avec nous en duplex bruno drop ski
storia un spécialiste de l'europe de
l'est ainsi que guy mettan députés du
grand conseil de genève journaliste
ancien directeur du club suisse de la
presse bonsoir à tous les deux merci
d'être avec nous on vient longuement de
le commenter beaucoup de médias
présentent cette rencontre de demain
entre anthony blinken et et monsieur
lavrov comme une rencontre de la
dernière chance vous le voyez également
comme cela dit mettant
vous écoutez d'abord merci de me donner
l'occasion d'exprimer
personnellement je pense pas qu'on
aboutira demain déjà une décision ce que
je constate
c'est que au moment la russie est le
seul pays qui a fait des propositions
puisqu'il a mis clairement sur la table
de propositions traité de paix et que
ces offres n'ont absolument pas été
prise en considération par la partie
adverse sans par l'autre dans les
européens et les états unis stockent
c'est quand même un peu spécial que on
réponde à ces offres et on peut juger si
ces sommes sont importantes il
s'intéresse en tout cas mais quand un
pays fait une proposition pour répondre
par des menaces et par une agressivité
surcroît d'agressivité
si on se réfère aux propos que vient de
tenir mon tony blinken il se rappelle
aussi qu'il ya eu des apports de minsk
ont été signés après les événements 2014
ces accords prévoient des modalités de
règlement de la crise de craignent elles
et je constate qu'à nouveau aucun effort
n'a été fait par la partie occidentale
total pour
réaliser ces accords aucune pression ni
de la part des américains et des
européens sur sur gouvernement ukrainien
pour mettre en oeuvre ces accords pour
raccorder changer la constitution
ukrainienne et notamment accorder
davantage d'autonomie aux provinces de
l'est au donbass donc on est dans une
situation complètement bloquée ou les
russes se voyante constamment agressés
par la progression de l'otan vous
décidez de faire de d'être clair sur
tout est clair et transparent et ya
aucune raison qu on n'admettra pas que
la russie un problème de sécurité
avec l'expansion de l'otan disent que
ces frontières on pourra pas sortir seul
titre situation malheureusement pour le
moment rien n'indique que l'on croit
qu'on en prenne le chemin alors en tout
cas le ton est monté en ces derniers
jours est aussi aujourd'hui à berlin on
dénie bingham qui a mené ces nouveaux
moscou de représailles en cas
d'incursion en ukraine et le discours on
le sait n'est pas nouveau mais enfin
tout de même comment interpréter ces
propos à la veille d'une rencontre qu'on
présente comme celle de la dernière
chance on montre ses muscles bruno
d'euros ce qui
est évidemment pour le moment il s'agit
pour les deux les deux protagonistes de
montrer leur fermeté c'est comme ça
qu'on prépare les réunions mais
effectivement
là les propositions reçues non seulement
de réponse mais nous même pas été
débattue que ce soit au niveau des chefs
d'état au niveau des structures qu'on
dit démocratique au niveau des
parlements au niveau des sociétés soi
disant 6000 on fait comme si la russie
attaqué alors qu'on oublie que l'otan
annexé la rb a
exclu il ne devait pas aller plus loin
on a lu ensuite l'europe centrale on a
lu ensuite les comptines république 1 de
l'union soviétique et aujourd'hui
la question qui se pose c'est est ce que
il y aura des missiles à 4 minutes 2006
c'est-à-dire en ukraine est ce que les
états unis sont prêts à admettre des
missiles à cuba
ou six minutes de washington à la
question alors nicolas de conc'air vous
évidemment on le rappelle vous vous
représentez les républicains enfin les
républicains en france
soutient donc et plutôt opposants à joe
biden pour être complètement transparent
il ya aussi les élections de mi-mandat
il faut montrer une forme de fermeté
dans le camp américain face à la russie
alors absolument il ya un contexte
aujourd'hui 20 janvier on célèbre le
premier anniversaire de l'investiture de
joe biden donc il y aurait tout un bilan
à dresser nous du point de vue
républicain on va être assez objectif
est sévère par rapport à tout ce qui
était fait en revanche on est aussi dans
une année voilà chargé le recteur
allemand avec les élections de mi mandat
je vais arriver en fin d'année où on va
élire une partie donc dé la chambre des
représentants et du sénat et pour
lesquels vu le contexte les républicains
sont très favorables pour reprendre et
le sénat et cette chambre des
représentants et donc qu'il est de bonne
augure en vue de la conquête de la
maison blanche en 2024 au moment où joe
biden lui est le plus bas dans les
sondages 33% d'opinions favorables c'est
un plus bas jamais atteint seule sa
vice-présidente fait mieux que lui qui
était encore en dessous et ils ont l'un
et l'autre en fait les velléités de se
représenter en 2024 mais voilà c'est on
est encore au stade des déclarations et
de montrer qu on y croit mais de fait
personne dé soutien et leur mesure leur
agenda ne colle pas avec les
préoccupations et quand ça marche pas au
niveau domestique on donne des
apparences de travail et international
quitte à faire des déclarations peut
être catastrophique alors hier en tout
cas il ya eu une déclaration de joe
biden qui a été copieusement critiqué
par les républicains aux états unis
avant de faire réagir dans un but et je
voudrais vous faire écouter le président
américain
donc je pense que ce que vous allez voir
c'est que la russie sera tenu pour
responsable si elle envahi et cela
dépend de ce qu'elle fait c'est une
chose si c'est une incursion mineurs et
que nous finissons par nous quereller
sur ce qu'il faut faire et ne pas faire
et cetera mais s'ils font réellement ce
qu'ils sont capables de faire avec les
forçats massés à la frontière ce sera un
désastre pour la russie si elle envahit
davantage d'ukraine et que nos alliés et
partenaires sont prêts à imposer des
sanctions sévères et des dommages
importants à la russie et à l'économie
russe alors c'est vrai que critiqué pour
cette notion d' invasion
d'incursions ne sais pas trop le chaud
et le froid sont faits par joe biden le
sénateur républicain arkansas times
cotone qui s'est même aller à un tweet
impuissance de joe biden à un rare d'y
venir poutine et voilà qu'il vient de
donner un feu vert à poutine pour
envahir l'ukraine est ce que c'est comme
ça que vous comprenez ça fait beaucoup
rire brume drop ce qui vous allez réagir
dans quelques instants dans sa guy
mettan c'est comme ça qu'on comprend
cette déclaration un petit peu
effectivement ambiguë de jubail
d'asnières
coûté pour moi je les trouve pas
tellement eagles la trouve tellement
justement anti russe n'a totalement
russo table que ce soit pas comment on
peut trouver cette déclaration ambiguë
et surtout si on se réfère à ce qu'a dit
anthony blinken c'est quasiment une
déclaration de guerre alors même que
comme on l'a vu la russie faisait des
propositions pour arriver à un accord on
n'entre pas du tout en matière au
contraire les anglais viennent de livrer
des tonnes d'armements à l'ukraine c'est
la réponse comme un porc propositions
russes en armant encore davantage des
ukrainiens franchement je ne trouve pas
que c'est une bonne manière d'amorcer
des négociations de paix quand c'est pas
comme ça que moi j'envisage de
négociation paie jusqu'à maintenant on
n'a encore jamais vu ça donc je suis un
peu sceptique quant à la volonté
du président by dell et les états unis
mais serait heureux d'écouter les
propositions du parti républicain à ce
sujet pour arriver à un accord avec la
russie rappelle quand même que je pense
car voici une tonne il ya quand même
certaines parties des élites à
washington qui a pris conscience que
avec la le conflit croissant avec la
chine et avait un intérêt de la part des
états unis à essayer en tout cas de
conclure un accord
rival sons d'arrangement avec la russie
telle manière que les états unis et pas
à combattre en même temps et la chine et
la russie mais pour moment ça paraît
totalement minoritaires
alors moi j'ai l'impression parfois
qu'on sait pas très bien s'il ya un
gouvernement à washington ou s'il y en a
deux ou trois parce que ça a vraiment
vraiment l'impression parfois que sa
tirade à lui et à dia alors il ya des
considérations de politique intérieure
il ya des polices des considérations de
politique étrangère mais on a parfois
l'impression que le pentagone mène sa
politique que le département d'état mène
sa politique que d'autres d'autres
dirigeants américains mais leurs
politiques évidemment c'est c'est cela
qui est particulièrement dangereux dans
la mesure où dans un pays qui peut
gouverner disons les 20 ans de guerre
évidemment ce qu'ils veulent et c'est
sans doute là
le pire c'est à dire que pete grande
puissance peut être critiquée mais quand
une grande puissance et gouvernés et
bien au moins on sait à quoi s'en tenir
tandis que là on a l'impression qu'on
m'a une grande puissance qui ne ti qui
va s'y qui ne sait pas ce qu'elle veut
qui montre les muscles un moment qu'ils
ont ensuite dans de petites incursions
puis de nouveau montre les muscles
lendemain par la déclaration de blinken
et là on a vraiment l'impression que
quelqu'un tient pas de pilote dans
l'avion en fait à washington
ce qui est sûr le beaucoup plus
dangereux que
que kate honda un pilote fusse-t-il
critique ni connaître au caire quel
intérêt et auraient joe biden à vouloir
finalement soutenir à ce point le cren
après le retrait catastrophique
d'afghanistan
on imagine que ne serait pas forcément
bénéfique pour lui jusqu'où est prêt
jusqu'où est il prêt à aller pour une
vacation parce qu'en face on à la russie
c'est une population de 150 millions
d'habitants
membres du conseil de sécurité de l'onu
qui détient la force nucléaire donc il
ya vraiment un contexte qui fait que
jusqu où est ce qu'on va pouvoir aller
et de fait est ce qu'on a les moyens d'y
aller est ce qu'il va être soutenue par
le congrès ou non la plus précisément
dans cette déclaration qui fait qu'on y
parle d'une incursion mineurs c'est
important de le rappeler et nous les
républicains on est très attaché à sa
souveraineté des états nations donc on
n'est pas en train de parler si on mord
dit sur le territoire c'est un état et
nation et toute violation de son
territoire et une attaque et qui a
effectivement appel ou condamnation l'a
effectivement de donner un blanc seing à
la russie ou une autre nation d'empiéter
sur le territoire d'un état nation c'est
vraiment quelque chose de catastrophique
du point de vue diplomatique ce qui a
appelé derrière à la maison blanche qui
a appelé à voile à des communiqués pour
éteindre un peu cet incendie mais basse
apporte vraiment une atteinte très forte
la relation dans un contexte déjà tendu
alors en tout cas aujourd'hui anthony
blinken a mené à des pourparlers avec
les alliés européens les voilà à la
veille de cette rencontre cruciale à
genève le chef de la diplomatie un jean
yves le drian était lui aussi à berlin
une façon bruno grossi de de montrer
aussi que les occidentaux sont bel et
bien eu ni éclat et la france a malgré
tout un rôle à jouer on les entend pas
beaucoup ces européens sur cette
question il essaie d'exister
les européens ont sans doute été dire
déçu du fait qu' on ne savait pas trop
consulter jusque là ce qui n'est que la
conséquence de leur alignement
systématique sur les etats-unis depuis
depuis au moins quelques années sans
aucune réticence on rappelle quand même
que la france a rejoint
l'organisation militaire de l'otan dont
elle n'était pas membre jusque là ce qui
lui permettait d'avoir une certaine
autonomie qui donne une certaine
crédibilité ce qu'elle n'a évidemment
plus aujourd'hui
elle apparaît comme un pion qui là aussi
ne sont sait pas trop on a eu le
président macro qui à un moment nous a
dit que le l'otan était en état de mort
cérébrale puis un an plus tard il est
devenu faucon dogue là aussi à la
question si on a un pilote dans l'avion
et c'est l'état de la plupart des pays
européens dans cette situation
évidemment
c'est la pire situation qu'on puisse
avoir puisque on ne fait pas vraiment
qui va décider de quoi et si un
partenaire ou un autre ne va pas mettre
son grain de sable est donc dans ce
contexte là rappelons quand même que la
crise et en ukraine on a réussit à un
état qui est en état de déliquescence
totale l'ukraine n'est pas un état
aujourd'hui c'est un c'est un
gouvernement avec des oligarques des
mafieux
qui est un pays qui n'est pas géré
dépenser beaucoup d'argent à fonds
perdus
c'est le résultat évidemment de ce coup
de force de 2014 qui a vu la
désagrégation de toute structure
étatique conséquente avec donc des clans
est donc d'aider des dirigeants
ukrainiens des oligarques locaux peuvent
faire monter la pression pour essayer
d'obtenir de nouveaux subsides
pour maintenir à flot
est déjà à moitié coulé aussi avoir ça
en tête le paysage que le tough
l'ukraine est lamentable par rapport à
tous ses voisins peut-être qu'avec la
moldavie c'est le seul pays avec lequel
il pourrait être comparé mais tous les
autres voisins tiennent mieux la route
que l'ukraine ce qu'il faut aussi que
guy mettan le mot de la fin pour eau
pour vous même tonalité à londres le
premier ministre gordon qui a prévenu
qu'une incursion russe en ukraine quelle
que soit son ampleur serait un désastre
pour le monde bon ils sont tous sur la
même ligne mais enfin
finalement au bout du compte est ce
qu'il ya vraiment une vraie union ces
occidentaux ils sont armés mais la
réalité est tout autre ou
des petites divergent il ya des petites
divergences entre me réalité il ya il
n'y a pas de ya pas de vraies
différences puisque ce rap et un comme
l'a dit monsieur valls qui sont
complètement alignée sur les états unis
cela dit effectivement je partage
l'analyse qui a été faite j'ai
l'impression
exacte des sous marins ou d'autres armes
là là là il n'y a pas de problème en
revanche ce que je pense on a
l'impression que du côté occidental tant
du côté des américains les faucons
qu'ils soient républicains ou démocrates
que du côté des européens au souhaite
presque une action militaire russe le
belle manière qu'on puisse refaire
l'unité contre la russie moi j'ai
l'impression que ces sacs pour eux parce
qu'on n'arrive pas à s'accorder
effectivement c'est un gouvernement
c'est un gouvernement mais pourrait dire
parce que c'est au point de l'ong acat
si vous permettez l'expression mais
qu'on souhaite cette intervention de
façon pour restaurer l'union sacrée de
des européens et des états unis contre
la russie comme ça tout serait pour le
mieux dans le meilleur le meilleur des
mondes
il ya eu des dissensions à cette crise
des sous marins australiens notamment et
pas que ce serait une manière de se
réunifier tout cela est d'éviter
peut-être une europe de la défense
notamment enfin au delà de ça ce que ça
caractérise tous apprennent de
leadership du côté de la maison blanche
la joe biden en a parlé ce quelqu'un qui
pilote l'avion là on le voit dans ses
réponses il est confus il s'exprime peu
à la presse il a fait à peine dix
conférences de presse on attend alors
que tous ses prédécesseurs on aura fait
le double dans la même période il ya un
vrai manque de leadership et de
management et qu'ils vont vraiment se
traduire par par des échecs haut niveau
la de la perte du sénat par par les
démocrates à l'horizon l'automne
prochain mais en tout cas on suivra
demain cette rencontre important qui
aura lieu à genève dans votre ville guy
mettan et merci à vous a tous les trois
messieurs d'avoir été avec nous pour ce
décryptage et c'est la fin de cette m